I'm the first exoneree to be exonerated
by an innocence project and being go on
to be a lawyer for an Innocence Project
the best thing to do with your anger is
to use it as the fuel that drives you to
reach goals in life my name is Jared
Adams and this is my story at the age of
17 I was sentenced to 28 years in a
maximum-security prison I was falsely
accused of a sexual assault I didn't
commit and I realized very quickly early
on they had another to do with the truth
it was about race if you can't afford to
prove your innocence or the court
affords an attorney to you my lawyer
convinced my family and I that a no
defense theory was the best theory of
defense it was a horrible idea and that
defense contributed to me being found
guilty I was incarcerated in prison so I
was there for almost a decade one day is
too long when you're innocent I was a
kid I was absolutely terrified my entire
youth was gone this is when boys become
men I missed out on all of that
I was at the time broken but when I
continued to see that my mother and my
aunts weren't broken and they were
fighting for my innocence I decided that
if I didn't have the energy to fight for
myself I most certainly can find the
energy to fight for them I started to
try to grasp the law I would get law
books law journals and read about
attorneys who were litigating cases in
the state of Wisconsin so I reached out
to the Innocence Project the
organization that advocates and
litigates on behalf of the wrongfully
convicted ultimately they accepted my
case the court unanimously decided to
overturn my conviction I ended up
enrolling at a four-year college where I
studied criminal justice after
graduating I obtained my law degree and
I became an attorney I had the
opportunity to exonerate another person
and it was special to me because it was
in the same state in which I was
wrongfully convicted I've now opened my
own law practice and I think that me
coming from a place like the criminal
justice system being wronged hearing the
stories and getting to know other men
who have been wronged
what better advocate could they have but
myself I strongly feel like this
happened to me for a reason it was
necessary to encourage the greatness out
of me
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
[Music]